there it is there's the lid
there's the lids it's it's uh it's
roughhouse
quarantine wednesday buddy
i wish
right now
because i'm feeling
pretty much 100 tomorrow i'm gonna get
swabbed make sure i come up with a
negative getting swabbed again friday
make sure i'm negative i did it
yesterday son
well
here's the thing brennan
monday i was feeling so good bry oh bro
i thought let me go on a long walk and
you know what let me
let me then do some weight lifting but
then let me not stop there let me eat a
bunch of food and then you know
maybe i'll um
maybe i'll go on a long walk again now
keep in mind this is outside with my
mask i'm very far away from everybody
but i have my dogs
and um
and and you see corona miss corona will
not be rushed she will take her respect
you haven't worked out before that right
you haven't worked out this entire time
no no but oh bro i thought why don't i
work my legs my back and my chest i feel
like you i feel like you're too old to
act like this dude you should know that
now
do you want me to tell you do you want
the fans to tell you when you read the
youtube comments that your neck looks
like clint eastwood's right now well now
listen that's because it's a bad angle
now hold up
that's your neck no no no no
i can't see anything you have the knack
of an earthworm well
my that might be covered neck one of the
things that i'll tell you is it it ages
your neck by five six years now listen
uh the next day i woke up and miss cobot
said you can take a seat now
you tried to rush things you take a seat
were you sore or were you got more sick
i got more sick
and i had to lie down the whole day and
now i'm back now i'm okay but now
o'brien's going to take his [ __ ]
sweet to
to time how weird is that i mean
obviously you're older so it's gonna
affect you different but it's like
it just shows you how weird this
freaking disease is because
you know three days into i'm biking 20
miles i just fight 24 miles right now
and didn't break a sweat it's almost
like
yeah well that's [ __ ] awesome because
a lot of people have issues with their
lungs
and uh hopefully i'm not one of those
but i'm doing an inhalable steroid which
is very helpful apparently you still got
the cough though huh a little bit
yeah i took my test even the lady doing
it she's like you seem totally fine yeah
i'm fine
because you should have it back in about
24 hours so i hopefully call me today
but you know we can't get back to studio
till you pass the test and chin passes
the test
that's right chin chin tested positive
how you feeling chin
it's been a weird you don't have a cough
which is good i'm good now guys
so i'll get the test and then hopefully
i'll come back
there you go
uh you know what's interesting about
this disease whether or not we gave it
to this chin or not when i would imagine
somehow we did
cat tested negative sitting right next
to him
i believe we kept at least six feet away
the whole time that one
b so in you know with king and esteem i
was i touched theo theo didn't get it i
pat didn't get it nick didn't get it
you know it's it's just it's weird [ __ ]
man
it's so [ __ ] weird it's that
it's a it's a wily
disease in that sense yeah you need
prolonged exposure from what i hear who
the [ __ ] knows that i'm reading in the
in the new england journal of medicine
that masks don't help and they're
largely symbolic i don't think i don't
know
we don't know how dude no i'm i'm so
[ __ ] sick of coving i'm sure people
are here sick of us talking about it
they're sick of zoom
oh dude
dude i'm i can't this is the last i'm
telling you guys this is the last zoom
i'm doing this is it we're going we're
gonna go dark after this i can't do it
anymore i can't no well we're i'm gonna
get tested tomorrow and friday yeah i
had two negative tests within 48 hours
uh you know hope you know what they did
to my results last week they lost the
results they just lost them
that's always good so i had to go in
there to make sure they didn't lose them
this time but how about this how about
i'm dropping tiger after school this
morning and it's the first time i've
ever embarrassed him so our thing is
rick and morty we always watch rick and
morty before he goes to bed and there's
there's a there's an episode on rick and
morty where they have like all their
friends or all the friends are popping
up they're actually aliens with the
disguise as their friends and they're
bringing back old memories and then they
pop up in the house and their old uncle
this italian guy in new york pops up his
name's i think uncle vinnie or something
like that and this whole catchphrase it
makes no sense he goes i'm walking here
right so you know where that's from
what it's actually from a movie called
urban cowboy oh really dustin hoffman
played a guy who was
a street urchin from the street
guy
and when when he was the cab almost hits
him when his cross really goes i'm
walking here i'm walking yeah so yeah
that's what it's from yeah so that's
that's this this hit the uncle of the
family that's his only line like they
they get trapped in the elevator and he
pops he like saves them and they go oh
uncle vinnie goes i'm walking here like
it makes no sense
so tiger and i will just randomly go i'm
walking here and then he'll say it back
so i went to
drop him off at school and he's there
with his little friends and the teacher
has his arm and i'm like bye tiger love
you guys love you and i go i'm walking
here
the teacher turns around she goes what
and i go oh nothing and then she looks
at tiger shows what's your dad saying
usually tiger says it back
he said nothing just shook his head i
could tell he was so embarrassed he was
so
[ __ ] embarrassment you remember those
moments there might be nothing worse
than being in here i felt so stupid
because the future turned out goes what
i go uh no and then i'm looking at tiger
girl i'm walking here and he just shakes
his head and i'm like oh wow when you're
younger
your biggest fear is embarrassment you
can make that argument you
high school
middle school
your biggest fear is embarrassment being
embarrassed oh dude i held in every fart
from from [ __ ] first grade until i
was a senior in high school i did no one
heard me fart
once bubba no i was in when i was in uh
my junior my freshman year in high
school
i was because i had to go to boarding
school and i was new to america
and i was
[ __ ] in massachusetts and i was
eating at some [ __ ] you know we sit
at the cafeteria and i grew up on food
from the countries i was in and i i was
trying to drink milk because i they told
me to make me bigger and stronger so i i
was drinking all this bad milk i farted
i was sitting down
i sat down and i
there was a table full of girls behind
me and i farted
and i farted i went as noise nobody
cares i went sick i like
like that and it reverberated across
against the plastic chair
so loud and
they all
all of them went oh my god
oh my god and i heard the girl go he's
pretending he can't hear us
[Laughter]
i
literally was like i'm never turning
around and i'm just going to keep
staring at my table
and
just
kept looking back and they wouldn't
stand there all like this he's like look
at him he just brought in my house and
he's not turning around
he's still pretending he can't hear us
and i was just like i've never been i
was plastic tears those flashy tears
[ __ ] ripped they just ricocheted dude
they betrayed me
we had a kid you know when i was going
to school they maybe it was just school
i was in they didn't separate the kids
they didn't especially they didn't
separate the kids with special needs and
the regular students for like recess or
anything like that so we we would eat
with everybody man even the kids who you
know had who were special
and there was this kid man
and he just he wore matching sweats
every day you know he was a little bit
uh on the special side and everyone
everyone was so nice to him nobody ever
bullied him everyone took care of him he
was like you know everyone loved them
and thinking back on something really
cool but
he always wore the same blue sweats he
had multiple sweats but he only wore
those every day and his underwear would
take out the back like his whitey
tighties but this kid just no [ __ ] given
he would just [ __ ] the loudest farts
you've ever heard and this is how cool
the kids were in the fourth and fifth
grade
no one reached no one made fun of them
everyone just kind of was like that's
that's roger you know like that's what
he does and now i think that kind of
like as a 37 year old man if that kid
farted right now i would bust out
laughing you know what i'm saying
when we were in italy
my sister myself my buddy ray briata and
his brother and his his wife
and we were
we were getting on a train and there
you're gonna think i'm joking it was
somewhere in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] italy we saw one dude who had
blonde hair who was wearing a swastika
around his neck he was wearing a gold
swastika he was a [ __ ] fascist and he
was blonde and really muscular and we
were like holy [ __ ] where are we and
then there was a family and you're gonna
think i'm joking of inbreds
they were a family of inbreds they were
a family mom dad
kids and they they were they were not
they were dangerous i said to my sister
stay over here and they were staring my
sister and they're eating and
i this is a i could hear them there was
a chorus of farts they were farting
as a family and we still talk about it
and just staring at us dude
i remember
going back to my son how i embarrassed
him i felt so bad as i was driving away
i remember when i was in third or fourth
grade i sat next to my biggest crush her
name was kathy lee something i remember
i just i had to pick my nose and we're
watching a movie and they sat me next to
her and whatever earth science i was
like oh hell yeah this is the hot chick
i have such a big crush on and i was
picking my nose and i lost it like where
the [ __ ] did it go
and then we're watching the movie and
then i like said something about whales
i was like how about this sperm whale am
i right and as i as i say something
shoots up and goes oh my god i go what
she was you have a giant
in front of the whole class she is you
have a giant booger right here dude
oh dude i reached up i felt it i oh my
do i you could have i wanted to die i
literally wanted to die that's like the
girl i was 18 and she was 21. i couldn't
believe she liked me in college again
[ __ ]
freshman year in college i have the
worst cold i'm blowing my nose
she goes what's that on your sweater
i know
i know
i don't know
it was a bunch of yellow
[ __ ] snot
and i went like that and i go i don't
know she goes i don't either and we both
pretended we didn't know
that i had a snot
all over my [ __ ]
fall sweater no dude when i was when i
was a freshman in college at where not
sorry i've been a sophomore i was a
registered
in colorado i bought this or i watched
this pit bull named pig he was this
little tiny pimple puppy cute as [ __ ]
and you know he's a puppy i didn't know
how to raise a dog i let him roam around
my [ __ ] dorm room well he must have
took a [ __ ]
took a [ __ ] on my cu football issued
hoodie that i wore all the time yeah it
was great and so i put i must have went
to the bathroom and i smeared the [ __ ]
under the hoodie woke up the next
morning i'd be at you know school early
7am i put the hoodie on and i'm i and i
the whole the whole time i'm driving and
i'm walking like it smells like [ __ ]
around here man
i get in the class and my my friend goes
god damn bro he goes bro you got [ __ ] on
your shirt
hey dude i had a pile of [ __ ]
just a [ __ ] pile of [ __ ] dude on my
sweater there was a gal in college i
still remember her she was so beautiful
she was uh her father would have been
black her mother was white
she was i couldn't believe she liked me
i [ __ ] couldn't believe it
and then we ended up having
sex in my apartment
and as we were and i was like i was like
her body was i was like i can't believe
she likes me i'm just like this is it
was just like one of those young man
experiences were like holy [ __ ]
and my dog
came walking up
right
she says there's been an accident
and i smell
of course what smells like only fresh
dog [ __ ]
my [ __ ] pickle
my [ __ ] dog is squatting and taking
the biggest [ __ ] of all time
right next to us but it ruined the
relationship ruined everything what a
nightmare man you [ __ ] dog buddy hey
buddy don't take a [ __ ]
right there
especially when
anyway dude you never forget these
things like the first time i was making
out with a girl i was doing in front of
like between classes first time i've
ever kissed a girl and this guy and
jesse was my friend cameron i forget his
lasting cameron oh cameron wilson i'm
making out with the girl you know the
kids are like watching like damn and he
pulled my pants down all the way down to
my ass cheeks and dick are out the front
that's a problem because when your
dick's not ready you don't want people
seeing your dick when you've just been
walking around it's not flattering i'll
never forget it man i'll never forget
that [ __ ]
yeah that's it that's i i yeah you don't
want to do that you got to do something
with your dick but jordan burroughs
maybe the greatest amer one of the
greatest american wrestlers wrestled
with ben askren in this exhibition match
and and jordan
jordan had
no underwear under his singlet and his
stick was just because he'd been
wrestling was all in
was it all bunched up
it was all bunched up and it was just
pointing and for this badass guy with
this
things just didn't fit the look well
when you're when i was like you've got
to wear you got to wear something to
cover that up so we know how it is when
when you're in high intense situations
your dick goes retreat it does it does
it doesn't mean he doesn't mean he has a
small one it just means in that
situation everybody's dick when you're
in combat mode everything pulls back oh
no he's not yes
he's
no he's packing your boy there uh is
packing serious all-american hate dude
yeah who is the who is the wide receiver
[ __ ] is it alonso not bowdoin no that's
a comic that's kind that's my boy alonzo
i'm sorry uh no it's it's uh anyway he
the best
for st louis i think for the cardinals
and he he likes to wear you know
not fitzgerald the other guy he likes to
wear um
bowdoin bowdoin no well uh uh
um oh he's retired now adrian uh bolden
yeah now he likes to wear
he likes to wear his pants
songs underwear songs which is french
for not without
songs underwear and the man even when
he's at a full sprint that man doesn't
have any retreat that man seems to be
doing very well sometimes nowhere to go
sometimes it's like a tail it's
basically a pain
it's got to just sit there it's got to
just sit there and take it as if as is
it's right as it's right yes yeah it's
the tail dude it's a tail yeah it takes
it takes its space it occupies its cubic
space because that's it's right so there
you go what uh what have you been doing
brian this i think it's the longest
we've gone without physically seeing
each other you know what brennan i i
don't do anything what i do is i watch
ballers
i watch
which i'm very into
and i watch uh and then i i walk around
my house
i i've not even taken a walk except for
monday until yesterday well yesterday
you said you went hard in the paint no
not yesterday monday i i took a walk
but no i i haven't even been really
going outside because of my
my covert but now that i'm i seem to be
very symptom free i
i take a a very socially distanced walk
to get into this could get the uh
the kobe test done are you going to them
are they coming to you
they're coming to me
i'm not going to go anywhere yet
you're going to wait to your negative
yeah i think so i think i think that's
appropriate
so because my insurance takes care of
some of that so
that's good
yeah
so you've had two tests
about three
oh
they lost negative they lost two they've
lost them
very annoying that's annoying
that's very annoying we got fights
tomorrow
tonight tonight
are they pay-per-view no
i'm i'm gonna watch those what time are
they on can we now uh probably six or
two you had to put your money on ige
or cater great fun i know i think i know
where you're going yeah i love cater but
ige is a monster man
i wouldn't bet on it
too close of a fight and he is the real
deal that dude brings it man
he's the real [ __ ] deal man yeah
what's his camp where is he trained out
of max hollis
uh he came from uh
the dana white contender series
a lot of good guys coming out of him man
he's a hawaiian cat he's a stud man
i wouldn't bet on it
i just
i want to bet on it i liked what you had
to say about i listen listen to you on
below the belt i like what you had to
say about um blessed and his
third fight is appropriate yeah give me
a third fight he's earned it he's a
legend man give him a third fight he's
only 28.
i'm not going to retire
like the division can't just move on you
know what i'm saying you can't just move
on from matt's halloween
[ __ ] no i bet if you ask alexander
wolkanowski he's gonna say the same
thing like yeah i would like a clear-cut
win before i [ __ ] move on
yeah they're they're saying that
pay-per-view trended towards 1.2 million
buys by the way
jesus fight island the real deal
that is amazing but what what helps is
what really helps is a guy like ma
doll
yeah man he's a draw i i love the guy i
just can't get enough of them i i you
know i i think it helps mazda i think it
helps us man i think it helps max alex
it helps everybody
yeah
do you think moz vidal are you very
intrigued by a rematch or do you think
the same thing happens with all due
respect i i don't think you can give
immediate rematch there's too many guys
waiting in the wings i think right i
think he has to be i think he can fight
colt it'd be smarter for mazda to fight
colby anyways because just make your
money man you're getting real money so
fight colby it's a good matchup for you
let usman take out uh gilbort or leon
edwards which is a wrist but um
you are you are you more worried about
leon edwards than you are about uh
gilbert
yeah yes oh yeah really
gilbert seems like a [ __ ]
explosive monster you've been fighting
for a long time b he's just on a you
know he's on the surge right now but
leon edward's a real deal man it was a
[ __ ] problem
he's won eight in a row for god's sake
he just he doesn't get enough credit
because he you know he's over in the uk
and he can't do [ __ ] yeah
that's true
that's true
yeah thank god there's fights tonight
something to do and saturday
and saturday who's fighting saturday
saturday's joey benavidez you've got
kelvin gaslum fighting
they're not none of the cards are like
stacked especially like that people for
two fight nights on a wednesday and a
saturday sign me up man
i'll take it i can't believe that baby
did 1.2 million in this in this current
climate we're in a [ __ ] depression
that's insane dude it's insane
that's remarkable
remarkable and pretty cool yeah it's
great
it shows you maybe the economy's
bouncing back a little bit i hope so the
market seems to be doing pretty well
dude how about you uh i don't know if
you you might have saw how about your
boy i did i sent it to you the the
article on nick cannon did you see the
nick cannon stuff i i did i didn't read
the article what did nick say he seems
like such a nice guy
i'm a huge net cannon fan man i think
he's brilliant he's a smart dude you
look at what he's done you know with his
producer brain
you know the guys worth
a lot of money a ton of money most stuff
that he does he owns so for instance why
that show while in out that's been on
mtv for 15 years he created and he owned
wow
you know and it's a multi multi-million
dollar business for him and then he
brings that same thing he go he does a
live tour of that in or all around
nation so that that's a big money maker
for him so he did it what's interesting
he did this podcast when he did it
i think he he did it like
a year ago he didn't you know because he
he's so busy he so he hosts the morning
radio out here he's the voice of 105.9
nikken in the mornings
then he hosts the mass singer then he's
wilding out then he has his own
syndicated talk show supposed to come
out too on cbs
and so he did this podcast it was a
while ago i know a long time ago that
months if not a year ago
and he came out these are his words
he was saying that blacks are the real
hebrews and blacks are the real jews and
that white people are less and that
white people are closer to animals
because the the pigment in their skin so
we're we're we're more prone to be
savages and all white people are evil
that's that's that's his in a nutshell
what he was saying
very bizarre for a guy that's smart to
say something like that
he's always made comments you know about
white people and stuff like that and you
know it's it's whatever
um the problem is is i know viacom
wanted to apologize and he didn't want
to apologize and then now he doubled
down on it and he he is he didn't issue
an apology today he basically was like
well if you know i tried meeting with
him behind closed door and to address me
and fill me on fill me in where i went
wrong and he goes and i didn't get a
response from the ceo of viacom and so
he goes uh give me my i think he said
the 100 million dollar value of while in
out i want all the right i own that show
so
100 million dollars you can do whatever
the [ __ ] you want yeah i don't think he
has 100 million but uh he's saying that
while and out's worth that much
i don't listen
the one thing you don't want to do
is uh
especially
not even now anytime you know to be
anti-semitic
especially what he was saying it's like
dude what benefit did you gain from
doing that man i don't think he should
be canceled i don't think he should have
lost his job i think people can learn
especially when you talk about a guy
nick cannon when you look at his full
body of work you know he's been doing it
he's been part of cbs showtime cbs
viacom for
20 years
do you think he will be canceled
well viacom fired him
so he's not he's not so he no longer
there he can't do wylan out um he's not
i can do the math singer you know
yeah
they wanted an apology and he doubled
down
well i i don't i'm not sure if that's
why they fired i think they just fired
them over the anti-semitic
remarks what
that blacks are the real jews that
they're the real hebrews
that you know
uh it got it got dicey man that's funny
because um i think moses second wife
rebecca or whatever no maybe that's not
her name she was from ethiopia
so there's this
there is a there is the tie between af
black africa
and
the jews from israel there's always been
this sort of meshing of the original you
know moses being you know jew
and uh
there's there's always been this kind of
like connection
yeah
you you got to leave i'm sure kat i
haven't heard eventually you got the
real comments when i ran like ah [ __ ]
nick
damn nick i like him again i'm not i'm
i'm not with this cancel culture man i
don't think people should lose lose
their livelihood lose their entire
careers you know based off one comment i
think you know you look at nick's body
of work that's not something we just
forget about 20 years ago no but there's
a lot of it going on there is a lot of
this canceled culture and there is
they're canceling [ __ ] you know i
mean it's it's it's
over really ridiculous things where
people are losing their jobs
and and that's your livelihood man and
that is much worse than people can
imagine you spend 30 years building a
career 20 years building a career and
you say some things that people don't
agree with i don't know what nick cannon
says i'm not even using him as an
example but there's no don't use him he
he said something bad yeah there's
people
much less much less oh for sure much
less but don't you notice
that this canceled culture and these
even these you know low-level comics or
whoever they are that go after other
people don't you don't don't you ever
notice that it's never somebody who's
doing well in their career that wants to
cancel somebody else
there's a common theme it's usually it's
usually a group
of you know people that aren't happy
with their lives who are going after
this person who has success up here well
that's always the case you're doing it
behind the keyboard yes there are a lot
of people who just enjoy destruction
but they're more interesting you have to
have nothing
people are far more interested in
destruction than in persuasion
think about it like whenever you see a
debate
one's easier than the other yeah you
know it's really hard to change minds
it's why i always like tip my hat to the
true feminists which are the women of
ufc and the ufc and vanna white i'm
telling you historically nobody's
talking about this and you and i have
talked about it but like if you want to
talk about the forefront of lgbtq you
want to talk about feminism women like
amanda nunez rose namajunas gianni and
jen jack valentina these women who
stepped into a cage
and showed men
in different countries including places
like dagestan russia that aren't
as progressive that women can do this
too
that does change minds it does it
changes hearts and minds and so if
you're talking about actually persuading
and changing the world and getting men
to see women in a more egalitarian light
you would be hard-pressed to find a
better example than the women of mma and
i'm serious and nobody talks about it
you would be so hard-pressed
and let's just talk a little bit about
it about amanda nunez who's a woman
whose girlfriend correct me if i'm wrong
is her corner
she's a fighter though too she's a she's
a fighter
she's a fighter and they they kiss
before that [ __ ] is that's
that's being seen by people from
countries that don't
have a very liberal view of lgbt
you mean like all of brazil brazil is
not that friendly towards the the gay
community all of
southern russia these are very
conservative places but it's hard to
deny human excellence human beauty and
human potential when you see someone
like amanda nunez who is gay and that
[ __ ] incredible at fighting and the
list goes on by the way i don't know who
else first of all i think i think think
of uh gina carano man you know everyone
forgets about judy chronicles talking
about george hold up you're talking
about this straight up supermodel
who was a world champion kickboxer and
she looked like that and then also found
great fights look at her fight with
cyborg
misha tate well yeah
well don't forget about ronda who's
basically voice gracie of women ronda
rousey feminine and a badass you're 100
right regina carrano was the first one
who you talking about a straight movie
star who also happened to be a world
champion kickboxer and her dad oh and
her dad played in the nfl too yes and
and one thing to keep in mind also is
that these women didn't do it by drawing
differences between men and women or
writing books or critical books of men
or what what they did was they they
they but through their actions they
showed us how similar we are and the
problem with identity politics is it
draws distinctions between groups and
what we should be doing is focusing on
the commonality between all of us and
one of the things that's great about mma
comedy whatever it might be is that you
either can punch people and you can
either knock somebody out or make
somebody laugh or you can't and
that's what i love about it so that
nobody gives a [ __ ] about
what color you are if you're good at
your skill you're good at your skill and
it brings us all together and what
happens is everybody's rooting for that
one person people are cheering for a man
and union don't give a [ __ ] about what
her sexuality is they don't care where
she's from they're just cheering for
an excellent human being yeah yeah
and that's important to keep in mind
that's the strength of
of of accomplishment and a meritocracy
that's where politics and and
uh this this weird identity politics is
really a problem it highlights the
differences and tries to separate people
it doesn't bring it doesn't it doesn't
focus on the commonality between no but
but also this
especially the culture of the society
where especially america right now is
they pick and choose what to be upset
about where of course
yeah we're you know if if you know
there's no and i was texting this uh a
few days ago i got riled up about it
there's no bigger hypocrite than the nba
there's no bigger hypocrite he's one of
my favorite
there's no bigger hypocrite than lebron
james this guys don't you know they want
to wear black lives matter on their
jerseys they want to wear all these you
know defund the police on their jerseys
and black lives matter new jerseys okay
that's fine
but but you know they have huge interest
in china right now what china is doing
to hong kong if you're if you what
you're trying to do into the eugers to
their their muslim minorities
i forgot you can't talk to the new
yorkers about it oh you can't because
they get disappeared and put in
concentration camps yeah they're their
human rights record is a great
outrageously it's a great the communists
they're communists and you know they
donate over uh you know or because of
business they 1.2 billion dollars to the
nba so when one owner for the houston
rockets i think he's a gm ghost hey man
i think we should be kind of concerned
what china's doing it their interest in
hong kong oh what happened he had to
apologize he got reprimanded and the
other started calling him out
yeah because it was affecting their
bottom line brandon yes it was affecting
money money talks not morality not not
nobody's nobody's morally consistent
that's why well all this all this got
started because uh i think he was a a
senator in missouri or minneapolis you
know the nba sent out this this whole
uh email chain to all the top
journalists and senators and stuff it
was like hey just want to let you know
the nba season is picking back up we're
going to allow the players to choose if
they want their last name going back
their jersey if they want black lives
matter or all you know whatever uh you
know defund the police whatever the hell
they can they can put a saying on the
back of their jerseys and the center
goes can they put save hong kong can
they put uh do you mind if they bring
that up and the head espn the very head
beat rider the insider nba insider his
name's uh wojanowski or they call him
woesh responded back [ __ ] you
and so that went everywhere that went
everywhere and he's like all i'm saying
is if we're worried about human rights
and decency and uh be consistent
yeah it's like
and then you guys have this interest in
china so when lebron he's always talking
about shut up and dribble you know like
they tell me to shut up and dribble i'm
more than a basketball player but then
when it comes to china and space jam 2
and then making your shoes when they ask
you to dribble you ask how high you know
what i'm saying so it's like you can't
my problem is is like dude you got to be
one way or the other here
it's just it's insane to me yeah are are
more people saying that
oh no no no no no no that's not that's
not the that's no no no no god no no
one's saying that you're not seeing that
anywhere you have you have people in
hong kong right now where they just
passed the
the law i think two days ago you have
the people protest hong kong you know
what they're doing they're waving
american flags hoping we notice so we
help them out
but we're we're too busy over here being
upset at colin kaepernick or defunding
the police
oh and how do you find the police going
look at the look at the cities that have
done it look at new york look at chicago
we get minneapolis look well to be fair
they haven't been defunded yet but
they're what happens is when when police
when there's that much pressure on
police officers they tend to avoid those
areas and when they avoid those areas
because their morale is low you see what
happens i mean chicago is late they cut
funding in new york b they kept funded
by a billion dollars in new york
i i don't know that that's gone through
though i don't think that that has
actually been uh implemented as policy
may have but the point is is that you're
right what happens is um
if you demoralize police forces in those
areas you have to be very careful
because they will literally avoid those
areas and one of the things is that um
the the
people don't talk about what this gang
violence in chicago
does to innocent black people that's
that has to be voiced as well that's
that's a very serious problem and the
answer might be more police in that
situation i just talked to i had a long
conversation with a homicide detective
in chicago who was telling me what it
really is like on the ground it's
outrageous
you know it's it's it's a [ __ ] it's
horrifying and um
you know again you got to be you got to
be
i think consistent and very very honest
about where the real problems lie and
where to place all our resources where
should we direct our resources and our
energy because you want to save his
money
he fund the police ain't the answer man
can look at the crime the places where
you define man
it's [ __ ] yeah sometimes though
there's an argument for any kind of
defunding program which means put more
more money into after-school programs
and things like that because the police
union has so much power so there's there
it's a more complicated issue defunding
the police not a good cash rate just
because it tends to put people into a
panic and there is room
there is room to give
politicians on both sides of the aisle a
lot of times would like to give less to
the police unions because they're so
strong and they do they will [ __ ] tax
your
your tax your tax bracket they they take
a lot of money so it's a complicated
issue but it's not complicated i don't
know dude
yeah
well you're just saying you have to be
you get morally and ethically uh
consistent that's all
who gets human rights and who does it
should be all across the board
yes
yes you're interested in china and space
jam 2 and your nikes get made yeah
that's uh that's not so consistent
no china has a lot of power though china
has a lot of power that kind of money
talks boy that kind of money talks
one of the things i think is really
interesting is i'm very naive to pro
sports but watching ballers is
interesting because of the amount of
[ __ ] that goes on behind the scenes like
your business manager your [ __ ] agent
uh your how the nfl conducts itself how
you have to be really you know careful
it's really interesting i mean it's in
one way yeah i mean you knew like
manager and agent it's it's no different
than what we do yeah no i did but it's
just like the whole draft and waiting to
get picked and i just a lot of stuff i
don't pay attention to the minutia but
uh [ __ ] man i mean you're you're when
you're an athlete your agent
and your lawyer and your business
manager play a big part in your life
guys at the end of the day if you have
student loans
and you are still paying the same rate
you paid
when you
got your loan in the first place you
might be paying too much
earnest is a company that allows you to
refinance
your
student loan and in many cases bring
down your monthly payment or restructure
the entire debt and by the way it takes
about two minutes to check your rate
online so this is not a very complicated
thing but it'll help you with your
monthly expenses and help you pay off
your debt sooner student student debt is
a major issue it's a major political
issue it's a major problem and a lot of
people have trouble getting getting you
know out from under that yoke so give
ernest um a chance and see if they can
help you because it could be the best
thing you could ever do
um so start
saving
uh our listeners get a hundred dollar
cash bonus bonus and bonus when you
refinance a student loan at earnest.com
fighter that's a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you refinance a student loan
at earnest.com
fighter get yourself financially fit and
earnest could be one of the best ways to
do that all right go to earnest.com
fighter today terms and conditions apply
so guys guess what
i went through this clear aligners this
whole thing for six months didn't really
keep up with it my teeth are back to
where they were
and so i am going to go i'm going to go
and become a customer of candid i have
decided i thought about this before we
actually even got this read
why am i going to do that i'll tell you
why and why i'm i mean with candid and
not some of the other competitors here's
why first of all they're comfortable
they're removable totally invisible
um but but they also only work with
orthodontist licensed orthodontists who
are experts at tooth movement not with
dentists and there's a big difference
um
and it uh basically you can kind of do
most of it
remotely all right
um
and here's what's really cool with
canada treatment includes remote
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan right so they don't
they don't bounce around a bunch of
different i want the same guy so he
knows exactly what's going on with my
mouth
you know otherwise if you get bounced
around they have to start from scratch
all the time that's a big deal and i
didn't know that until i i researched
this um and the average can of treatment
is six months which i think that's
probably what i'll be because i just got
to fix the bottom part of my teeth but
man when you start thinking about this
and you start noticing people's teeth
most people don't really have that 100
watt smile and so that's kind of
what i'm looking to do
why not i did my eyes why not my teeth
why not your face you know
um anyway ready to take your first step
toward getting your dream smile you
can't wait to show off we'll get started
today with the comfort of in your own
home with canada's risk-free starter kit
and 75 off go to candid candidco.com
fighter and use code fighter that's
candid co.com fighter code fighter for
your risk-free starter kit and 75 off
candidateco.com
a lot more guys like you know there's a
lot more guys who are just doing it
themselves yeah
well i'll tell you where there's a lot
of money way more than an acting in
hollywood is in pro sports i mean when
you die you're talking about i've seen
money in this town but i mean you're
talking about young men who are 26 24
who have 40 million 50 million dollars
in the bank
right
[Music]
between i mean you know i if you if you
like the average salary and then they're
also not the best financial planner so i
don't know if that i i'd say it's very
rare that 40 50 million dollars in the
making we're talking about
i mean patrick mahomes just did sign the
biggest
you know contract in american history
what is it
i think the deal overall is worth 500
million over 10 what
what
oh my god and then and then dak prescott
for the cowboys they've been trying to
do a long term deal that's how crazy
things are getting
they offered him a guaranteed you know i
think it's like four years 100 million
dollars guaranteed he turned it down
what first hundred million dollar
contract turned down the nfl
how do you turn that down he thinks he
can make more so what they're going to
do if you don't come into the deal what
teams can do is they're going to apply
to the franchise tax so if they pay the
highest you know so he'll make
so it's a one-year deal they franchise
tag him he'll make like 33 million this
year
let's just show you how rare of an
athlete he is i guess right how reliable
so i showed you the market it shows you
the market for a good quarterback and to
me he's not even a top 10 guy you know
he's never good no he's never won a
playoff game he has the best o-line in
the [ __ ] in the world he has the best
run running back some would say is good
defense good coaching and he goes eight
and eight or nine and seven doesn't win
a playoff game so it's like
damn
damn it's so fascinating no wonder you
wanted to be a pro football player
though because if you do get that
certificate no no no see that that's the
problem that's like saying i want to be
a comedian because kevin hart makes a
millionaire yeah of course of course
what you're looking at you're going oh i
want to be a football player because
patrick mahomes makes 500 million in 10
years no no dude most of those players
are in and out of the league in two and
a half years three years and that's yeah
we don't have savings oh for instance
that dak presa he's been on his rookie
contract for the past
i wanna say four years he's been with
the dallas cowboys in total from the
cowboys he's made two point seven
million dollars that's it that's it man
so you get out of the taxes that's not
doing no you're not you now don't get me
wrong he has outside incentives and
endorsement deals like campbell soup and
stuff but you know if on your rookie
deal you're not making a ton of money
man you got to prove yourself and that's
why patrick mahomes you know they think
he's the future and he's going to be the
greatest ever they paid what he's worth
but
but a lot of you know most guys are
making those crazy crazy deals because a
lot of it you know i guess there's more
guaranteed money now thanks to their nfl
players association but basketball and
baseball is guaranteed money son so if i
play
for the nuggets one game and i signed a
four-year deal for 200 million dollars
and i roll my ankle or i break my leg
you owe me 200 [ __ ] million dollars
dude really yeah the mets are still
paying bobby bonilla
what yeah from like so so free but
football football if you get injured
you get
damn football's nothing's guaranteed
like when you sight like that's what's
crazy about dax's contract i can't
believe he signed it he didn't sign it
they guaranteed him a million dollars
dude a hundred million dollars take
money take that [ __ ] money
well what he's saying is
uh i'll take the franchise tag so pay me
whatever 32 million this year with my
endorsement deals i'll probably make
another 10 million and then if you want
in
french and not give me another big deal
next year you have to franchise tag me
again which would be another
40-something million dollars she's like
so i'm gonna make about the same without
signing this long-term deal
how long was the deal for 109
i think it was four or five years it
seemed like a good deal again i don't
think he's that great man
sign the [ __ ] deal yep i don't know
man i know
because with football you can get hurt
so easily now the one thing about dax is
he doesn't get hurt he's never missed a
game he's healthy
big guy
sturdy like i think six two two thirty
like sturdy a lot of us also having an
eye peripheral vision see when the storm
when someone's coming and being able to
protect i think that was peyton
manning's uh his gift was his ability to
kind of
see before other people could see when
he was about to hit and then brace
himself that's it if you get hit blind
side you get [ __ ] up well yeah
and just other professionals everyone
knows that but the same with like
the same with like time wow uh anyways
tom brady like but but again like tom
brady was so good at it because he
didn't want to get rid of the ball he
didn't take big hits
prescott again he has the besso line in
the league man he's the best running
back in the league so there's not that
much pressure to get the job done peyton
manning had great offensive lines he had
great receivers great running backs tom
brady had you know
he had he had a good team man great
coaching great game plan stuff like that
yeah
yeah the thing i just want i got to
start working on my footwork and my
[ __ ] release
because i want to make some money i know
dude i was watching patreon homes using
this celebrity golf thing and you know
live sports i'll watch anything at this
[ __ ] point so they had patreon homes
on there they had i think maybe drew
brees was playing john smoltz they had
some other oh uh steph curry was playing
but i was you could tell like
like patrick wilhelms was a guy who knew
knows he's making 500 million dollars
he's like hitting the ball like whoa
you know like i think you think how good
he must feel
[ __ ] amazing well why because he won
the super bowl he was super mvp and then
just signed a 10-year deal worth 500
million the biggest
he's also a good looking dude and he's
got the whole world that is
the football players again i i don't
have direct experience that but when
you're up an all-star football player
you're basically a god i mean you're
basically uh you're you're you've been
treated like a prince
since you were
16.
well
before that i mean if you're for that if
you're if in uh you know pop one or
little league or if you're a freshman in
high school and you're on varsity you're
stunned it's
so if you're adrian adrian peterson
you've been you've been treated like
like just uh loyalty man you know
truly like he like yeah you're just a
hero
everywhere you walk oh and by the way
you're a stud you're also a great
looking dude
not all of them but yeah i mean hey i
need you
so you've been watching ballers i need
you to calm down because that's an older
show too so i need you to calm down and
they have the rock i think the rock's an
agent in it so you got to calm down i
won't calm down and i'll say something
about the rock
his acting is
he could have used
all due respect i love the wrong hold on
hold on before you carry on he's the
highest paid actor of all time go i
understand i just
i just he could have used a little brian
callum he could have used that workshop
yeah i would have just little tweaks i
would have just
have you seen him in like jumanji or
like he's
he's a great actor i think you know
i think he's just coasting in that
[ __ ] show i think he was so busy
that he just had time to show up and do
his lines i really do that's what i have
yeah
i mean he was doing everything i don't
know how he [ __ ] did a tv show
because that's that tv show there's a
lot and he's there all day i can
guarantee it because i can see how they
shot it and it's actually heavy acting
it's not easy so he had he was doing all
these movies and that that's that's a
heavy load man that's a heavy look so
considering that's what i mean is i
could see he was clearly
probably exhausted probably like didn't
have time to do ten takes and just was
like let's go yeah
yeah but yet you love the show so sure
yeah i love the show and i love the rock
so it doesn't really matter yeah shut
your little mouth oh you know what i
heard dude i i'm on [ __ ] nick cannon
in the mornings they were talking about
this i listen to nick cannon me my son
do when i drive to school so i hear nick
can in the morning hopefully he don't
get fired from that but uh
they were talking about the celebrities
that make the most money with their
instagram swipe ups or a post
you know what you know who's the highest
who gets paid the most to post on
instagram the rock
how much he gets paid per post brian
it's gonna hurt my feelings
it's gonna hurt my feelings
what do we got
1.15 million dollars per post what are
you talking about
damn it he makes money
he's he is undeniable now he is is he on
all the steroids or just a couple
because i don't know but i'd like to i'd
like to know his doctor because i would
i mean i don't want to be that jack but
i'd love to get shred city dude yeah
here's the thing he looked we couldn't
have looked better
i was so happy with his thickness in
ballers
but you know when you do it for that
long the problem is you're um
you get older it makes you it ages well
your skin your skin can only hang tight
for so long your skin gets [ __ ] weird
when you're running in gear papa when
you're running here poppy it ages
it was like it's like using nitrous on
your car all the [ __ ] time it's true
you don't think the rock who makes a
million bucks to post some stupid thing
on instagram you know i mean he has more
money than god you don't think he has an
entire staff monitoring his blood cell
count his [ __ ] cholesterol his blood
pressure how much he could take what
foods he should eat that dude i bet is a
[ __ ] machine
he probably is but he still looks like
he's taking a lot of running gear
he's still running gear that's fine it
looks great though
he's got veins the size of my index
finger running through his entire body
i'll tell you right now if our boy todd
feldman called me and said hey brendan
listen i was talking to jerry
bruckheimer they're having him direct a
new batman
we want you to be batman but you got to
gain 30 pounds of muscle
and here's a number i would call that
number before i even hung up the phone
you'd be so excited to go on juice
just for once to get shredded oh dude
use your little picture me like this
with my dick root out all the time yep
and lose your little punch so you could
wear like
shorts that were low
and have hidden muscles but hip muscles
for the first time
did you say punch
you got it you got some nerve
what turkey gobbler neck
what i said
you got a little no you know you got you
know you've got a little bit you're a
little soft in the middle that's a
little soft in the middle earned it
i haven't earned it
well that's your one that's your one
achilles heel we got a little
tummy time here's the thing now when
papa gets stressed out or i i can't go
into studio and i get depressed because
these zooms suck my [ __ ] right when i
get sad what i like to do is i like to
eat i don't do drugs i don't drink i
like to eat i'm not making this up i've
ordered
two large
pepperoni extra pepperoni extra sauce
pizzas from domino's for seven nights in
a row and you eat you eat two do you eat
both of those i don't need both of them
i i i'm not gonna lie to you i'll eat a
whole one myself and then mean tiger
shear the other
one and listen it and now tiger's so
used to me or pizza what me and him will
be
let me hang it out and he'll go
you know he's so [ __ ] cute he looks
and goes papa i think we need a fresh
pizza
a fresh pizza
he's so goddamn cute oh dude when he
goes pop i need some fresh pizza i'm
like i think you're right buddy
i love that he that that your girl puts
cologne on him yeah he smells so good
i'll give him a kiss and i'm like oh he
smells like a little he's got that it's
like this subtle it's not even clones
like this subtle little lotion or
something that's uh yeah it's just like
kid lotion with a little scented and he
smells [ __ ] good though it's so great
he keeps asking me i hit up uh our boy
jeff
you know he keeps asking me he goes
where's muchacho jeff
tempest is closed again so we can
find our way over there i know he keeps
asking that i go dude the sickness and
it's busy goes
why they they don't like me i'm like no
dude it's not that they don't like you
it has nothing to do with that i know
it's about we'll get them back out there
uh let's keep it up i gotta leave in
about
20 15 20 minutes go pick that kid up
let's do some current events jim all
right let's do it that's good
brandon i've been asking you for a whoop
bracelet let's go
get me something i need whoop i know now
that i'm now i'm getting back into
training i i literally need to start
tracking my recovery i want to track my
sleep i want to track like how how much
i move during the day i want all of it
you think your lungs are ready papa
they're going to have to be they're
going to happen
whoop will keep track of all that stuff
for him
heartbeat
it measures like my heartbeat 100 like
100 times in a second a second son it's
the best workout device i've ever used i
started because i wanted the thick boy
nation to get their asses in gear
because everyone's guessing how many
calories they're burning how many hours
are going to sleep should they ride long
this week should they ride short are
they recovered take all the guesswork
out go to woop.com promo code fighter
you save 15 off the subscription the
device connects to your phone it tracks
everything you do it records from your
heart
rate 100 times per second man your
strength i like
it has a five-day battery life it has a
five-day battery life and i like the way
it looks it's smaller it's like
literally a
they just dropped some dope colors you
like to swim around brian you can wear
in the ocean you wear in the pool i'm a
water i'm an aquaman dude i'm all water
baby dude we're just a couple aqua boys
in this wild world dude yup couple aqua
boys
be an aqua boy we're the whoop strap
woop.com promo code fighter you save 50
off the subscription get your mind right
take the guesswork out of it woop.com
promo code fighter
so guys uh
on it
right now with covid there's nowhere to
work out is there
but
you can go to onit.com go to the on at
six go to their their home streaming
workout plans
uh usually a half hour and the best
workout you can find the one thing i
find when i go to on it in austin
is that gym has this they they their
trainers are state of the art you can
get everything you need in in a half
hour
and the website itself is actually a
really good source for information when
it comes to nutrition when it comes
comes to training tips when it really
comes to all things about optimizing
your body i think
personally they have the best
supplements you can buy on the
marketplace and people call me and say
hey is this honest stuff really for real
well here's what i always say i go look
the owners of the company the owners
started the company because they were
already taking these supplements and
wanted to make sure that the supplements
they were taking
uh were
the purest ones they could find the most
effective
so
the owners themselves are very hands-on
they take their own product the people
at the on headquarters take their own
product they're not taking other
products nobody's taking uh uh you know
a different kind of protein powder
nobody's taking a different kind of fish
oil nobody's taking a different kind of
corset mushrooms for for training or or
a different kind of nootropic to take an
alpha brain
so
you know um
it is in my opinion the best supplement
company on planet earth and it's an
amazing
source of information for a lot of stuff
so there you have it all right
on it dot com slash fighter 10 off
we got you out there hey cat you still
hanging around yeah what's up girl
what's up
what's up girl
oh i like that shirt little tie-dye oh
thanks
it says have a nice day yep and then a
skeleton
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah very grateful dead
and then chin what do you got oh you got
the original one love brian's shirt on
yeah
right
ryan do you remember that when you went
one love man and how mad i got remember
that no you just went like this i went
one love and you went you went
like what wait what did you say i was
like
i meant it
um you know what we should do we should
we should post the are the best clips
you know the vintage clips we should
post those once a week
that's a good idea buying cute clips
that's a good idea who's going to
remember we should have the fans email
the best clips to take out chin
yeah that sounds good so to which email
though
uh you could do uh
finally the find the kids shop at
gmail.com send it there and then json
youtube yeah sounds good
good idea here we go
okay this is a really sad one um do you
guys
know
who grant
is from mythbusters
i was
busters yeah their engineer for the b
team he passed away two days ago because
he had a sudden brain aneurysm overnight
and he passed away
that's terrible
a young guy
very young and it just hit him out of
nowhere out of nowhere
you
i'm not trying to make this about me but
i'm saying how [ __ ] great mythbusters
is you know i was on mythbusters and the
the only reason i did is because my
dad's favorite show and the guy who
looks like a walrus my dad wanted to
meet him so bad so i brought my dad to
the set they shoot in san francisco i
don't think they do the show anymore but
i've never seen my dad happier man
they're smart that whole that whole
staff there they're so [ __ ] good at
what they do man so smart
so
they're engineers and that guy who died
was one of the engineers i bet he was
really smart i saw him a bunch i'm not
sure that's such a bummer man that's so
sad
yeah
what else you guys got
okay so on monday they announced that
they were going to change the washington
redskins team name and there is a man
somewhere in washington a huge fan he
actually
saw this coming a couple years ago and
so he bought a bunch of potential
washington like name changes so if the
team wanted them he could just give it
to them for free because he didn't want
someone else to come in oh that's cool
get a bunch of names and charge them for
it that's cool
you know you know they're not calling
the redskins anymore right b do you know
this oh yeah i did this but this has
been going on since i was in high school
forever when i was in dc in college when
i was 18 they they were always talking
about how the redskins is an offensive
name
it's been twitter they've been talking
about this for 30 years
they're finally doing it and there's
some cool names like my favorite one is
the washington red tails for the for the
fighter pilots in world war ii the
african-american fighter it's cool
very cool
yeah man i mean you know i've never i
never cared i never
was attached to any name like that i i i
get it
the redskins is a little tough man but
then also but also they always suck
here's the other thing like dan snyder
has to be one of the worst coaches i'm
sorry worst owners of all time it's like
dude figure it out there's obviously a
[ __ ] problem man like
you're not good at what you do you know
they're never [ __ ] good dude no it's
just got a big ego yeah a huge ego and
he needs to get out of the way and they
you know they have so much money man
they should be such a better team and
they're in a [ __ ] conference too dan
snyder can suck it but here's the thing
the red the rip the red tails
yes
red tails would be sick
that's actually one of the names that uh
the guy bought up back in 2005.
you want to hear the lamest one i heard
washington monuments
that's another one he got oh [ __ ]
washington monuments washington
monuments okay
that's no good you know the cl the
cleveland indians they can't have the
the indian as a mask the little you know
the little red indian who's awesome that
can't have them on their jerseys anymore
why
they're getting rid of them i i forget
his name
i forget the indians name when i when i
was a kid you know i did and this was
pretty [ __ ] cool at the time i think
of it i was about eight years old i got
an indian's hat with the indians smiling
on it i took a gold sharpie and put one
of his teeth gold and wore it to school
every day a natural designer buddy
pretty cool man i'm to need you to
design a t-shirt for me
a rink's t-shirt
oh no i want a master kim rink's t-shirt
i want to read it that's what i want to
do
okay now i want to design these nuts in
your mouth how about that buddy you can
try but we might go surf and turf and i
don't give a [ __ ] anymore so you know
what i'm gonna do papa when i see you
and you're covered free i'm gonna take
that that lizard skin this i don't have
losing skin you're you're whatever your
camera's doing i got beautiful i i have
a beautiful night here bubba i'm gonna
take it and i'm gonna i'm gonna [ __ ]
make you wear a human mask like this
i you know in afghanistan when the soap
normally do i'm gonna make it like like
an uncircumcised dick i'm do that to
your face like this well they used to
take
they would take when they capture you in
afghanistan
they would cut your
cut all the way around your
waistband then take that skin
and pull it up
over your head and tie it
so you'd be in your own skin bag are you
making this up bubba no i'm not no i'm
not all the time i was taking that extra
lizard iguana skin he got there and give
me a [ __ ] circumcision i don't have
any lizard iguana skin dude i have tight
skin i don't know what your camera's
doing bro
you're here
who the [ __ ] is laughing over there
what else you guys got all right here we
go
chin i see those dumbbells in the back
where he is
what yeah
can you scroll down to the video
all right it's going down
uh that one okay so this video went
viral because a bunch of bakers are
making cakes that look like other things
and
for some reason people are very
intrigued
that tastes like that that cake looks
not tasty
and it's
not appetizing at all did you see the
one that family did of their baby and
then they cut the head yes that's so
weird that's so weird
wait let me see more of these this
should i play this video yeah yeah
30 million views
that's a cake
these are all cakes
that's incredible
i would eat that who's that chocolate
too okay
that's amazing
that's genius no
come on
dude a piece of soap
dude
come on
that's a mochi
that's [ __ ] remarkable
no
no [ __ ] way god brian you're easily
impressed huh
yeah jesus no [ __ ] way
no way
[Music]
no way wait wait do you see avatar
no
what the [ __ ] you guys no
no
not possible
what the [ __ ]
god is it is there a dairy queen by
anybody's house i would love some
[ __ ] dairy queen right now you're not
getting [ __ ] brandon shut up
no that's not there's no way that
there's no [ __ ] way that's okay
there's no there's no [ __ ]
oh what the
[ __ ]
no way impossible this is where i draw
the [ __ ] line this way i draw the
[ __ ] lie there's nobody now yeah and
hey old [ __ ] hey rest of the younger
people i found uh i found a dairy queen
it's it's 15 miles away i'll pick up
only
all right you go have fun with your
goddamn dairy queen next current event
please give us one more chin now that my
mind's been [ __ ] blown
oh brian is your taste back
nope
sure ain't
in fact things taste terrible my taste
is bad but coffee and wine everything
tastes like [ __ ]
how about yours
yeah i'm fine
yeah i'm bad 100 hundo
i i'm i'm not just saying this man i'm
telling my energy since cobit is through
the [ __ ] roof dude
right literally i came straight from 24
miles straight to here i'm still sweaty
i'm wearing my [ __ ] workout gear
shout out to sick boy ut new merch
hello
man brian
the bride's free
all right one more i'm taking phone
calls for god's sakes this is a great
one
so
this is a police officer
saving a three week old baby and the way
he handles himself the way he how he's
calm and professional is just using the
watch
hey what's going on with the baby okay
okay let me okay calm down hold on hold
on let me see the baby
okay hold on i'm gonna see the baby
he's still blinking he's blinking
okay hold on
he's crying he's crying
[Music]
the mom didn't think to try that
i don't know i mean
people don't study [ __ ] cpr and you
should some parents don't know that you
know you can do that as far as helping
the baby but the the way the cop was
apart from this
guy he was just so calm and natural and
just everyone yeah that was cool man
it was beautiful
thank god
thank god it's right that's scary
yeah
that's the worst thing ever
was nightmare
well b and chin hope you guys uh hope
you take tests soon
brian take your test dude so we can get
back in that studio oh i will
please i beg you
i thank you
all right kids
all right guys love you
love you too next time we're in studio
see you soon yep see you soon bigboy.com
new merch just drop get it thick easy
love you guys this is the final kid